former managing editor at time magazine
from new york this year's national book
critic circle award ceremony and
throughout the weekend look for
highlight at booktv.org
john brady appeared on book notes in
1997 to talk about his new book bad boy
the life and politics of lee atwater it
focuses on the life and career of the
former republican national committee
chair and party leader during the 1980s
mr atwater died in 1991 from a brain
tumor the program is an hour
[Music]
i'm brady that's not the way we normally
open up this program what's that music
that's the music from uh red hot and
blue an album that leatwater recorded
with bb king
and a all-star cast of blues
musicians in 1989
the year that
lee was chairman of the republican
national committee
a very unusual thing for a chairman of
the republican national committee can
to do but as you can see from the cover
of the book lee was not your average
republican
he was sort of a stand-up republican
he was an elvis-like
performer in the republican arena
and he
in the picture on the cover of the book
dropped trow
this is also a picture from 1989 that
appeared in esquire magazine for a
feature called
one leg at a time and it was a
photograph taken by lou salvatore a
a
young photographer who covered a lot of
celebrities and included atwater in the
mix because he had become a political
celebrity very unusual
most republicans don't have the
celebrity or the notoriety that we
acquired in office
and uh he was one of a kind when did he
die
he died in late march of 1991 after
battling brain cancer for about 13
months how old was he he was 40 years
and one month in three days
somewhere in your book you say he was
the best political campaign manager in
history i believe he was
why
well
he seemed to bring all of the forces
that other campaign managers had
together along with tremendous power of
personality
he had
he had a hard driving spirit and an
ability to organize things and to
motivate and manage others and to know
exactly where he couldn't do something
and where he had to hire someone else to
do the same thing
he had a remarkable record he won over
40 races in a
rather short political lifetime
you see rather well-known political
managers today who perhaps have won
eight or ten races in their careers
lee had done a lot more
along the way to learn every little
aspect of the craft he didn't just
become a strategist after a handful of
races he learned how to conduct mail
campaigns how to organize telephone
campaigns
how to change the message for a
a candidate who may have been too
complicated how to simplify things how
to streamline things
he had incredible intuition as a
campaign manager he also knew how to
step in front of the campaign
in front of the candidate occasionally
and take the heat to deflect things from
the the candidate
so he did a lot of things that today i
think are probably taken for granted in
certain quarters and a lot of people
have learned from him a lot of people
imitate him or try to imitate him and
they get maybe a little bit of his
his persona but
he was uh he was unique he was
distinctive
there was certainly a downside to what
he represented as well as an upside
he was controversial
and he died at the peak of his powers in
a moment i want to show a picture that
was originally published in life
magazine but before i do that uh i want
to ask you about his brother
joe
yes because you write about that a lot
right
in the early research for this book
i came across what i would call the
family secret
and it occurred in 1956 in the fall 1956
when lee was five years old
and it occurred in the kitchen of the
family home in aitkin south carolina
by the way which one in this picture is
joe
joe is on the right hand side
age three and although he's about two
and a half in this picture and that is
lee on the left
this was taken about six months
before
the the tragic accident
in the
in the fall of 1956
lee and his brother joe
were
at home with their mother toddy and uh
she was waiting for harvey her husband
to come home from work he was an
insurance adjuster and he had always
been on time
and on this one particular day he was
running late
a uh
a customer someone had come by and had
gotten his attention he couldn't seem to
shake him so he was going to be home
late in order to
put some
to keep the kids distracted for a
certain period of time toddy decided to
make donuts
she put a a deep fat fryer
on the stove and plugged it in
and started to make the
the batter for the donuts when she
turned around she saw that little joe
had wandered over toward the stove and
climbed up on a basket near the stove to
see what was going on
and as she said
joe get away from that that's hot
the basket slipped and joe
started to fall he reached up
and he grabbed the cord and of course he
pulled
the boiling oil down over himself as he
hit the floor
he started to scream and lee came
running in from the next from the living
room where he had been watching some
television show
and at that moment harvey came through
the front door and
everybody was in a state of panic
and there were screams they
put joe in a blanket and took him to a
hospital
even as he was being treated at the
hospital the doctors were weeping it was
it was such a devastating thing to to
be witness to and to be part of
and that later that afternoon joe died
for the rest of his life
the outward forbade anyone from talking
about joe
in his family no one spoke of joe
they internalized everything and even
when there was some slight mention of
this event
both harvey and toddy would start to cry
so atwater grew up
living with his
younger brother even though he was dead
at the age of three
competing with a presence
and he he became a uh
someone who desperately wanted attention
not that he was lacking in love i think
his mother who was the strongest person
in his life
was very very loving but there was still
a gap here at home
a sister was born later and it was i
think a good
family relationship
there were no traumatic events after
this
but
they could not talk about joe and
it affected lee's personality as i've
said
not until he was on his deathbed
could he talk about joke with his mother
and at that point he was so far gone
and had been so devastated by cancer
that even though joe had died in a
matter of 16 hours and lee died over a
period of 13 months
he said to his mother wasn't joe lucky
wasn't joe lucky he told a few
confidants toward the end of his life
that he heard joe's screams every day
for his life even though there was
nothing he could do about it except
suffer along with it here's a photograph
of president reagan lee atwater there in
the middle strom thurman and who are the
two people on either side
on the left is uh harvey atwater lee's
father and on the far right is toddy
atwater harvey died six weeks after
lee's death and
he died in may of 1991
he was battling cancer as well
while his son was dying at the age of
40. so toddy
buried in her lifetime her her son joe
at the age of three her son lee at the
age of 40 and her husband she's a
remarkable woman
here's a photograph that was in life
magazine originally and it's the last
photograph in your book when was this
taken
this was taken in november of
when lee was
on the ropes with
his in his battle with brain cancer
he was struck with a brain seizure in
march of 1990 and he
shielded from the press and from all
inquiry inquiries the
actual nature of his illness and
he was told when it was diagnosed that
he would have perhaps one year to live
he decided on an aggressive
form of surgery interstitial an
interstitial procedure whereby ten holes
were drilled in his head
and radium seeds were dropped into the
into the holes and in effect they bombed
the tumor
well the operation was a success in
a manner of speaking
the tumor
was bombed and there were enormous
amounts of dead brain tissues
dead brain cells
but the side effects as i said were
devastating he lost the left side of his
body in a matter of weeks
and gradually lost complete control of
the left side of his body
he had always had a
a leg twitch his his left leg was always
always twitching if you were around him
it would be jittering it was very
difficult to sit still in his presence
that stopped but then the twitch moved
to his right leg
he uh increasingly was dependent upon
drugs and the drugs especially the
steroids had the bloating effect on his
appearance
making him look almost [ __ ] he was
in a wheelchair uh he had very little
self-control a man who would in his
prime run six hours a day was now in the
hands of his handlers and
that photograph was taken by a
remarkable photographer for life
magazine named lynn johnson who
accompanied lee for about 10 days
total
as he
went about
certain forms of business that he could
conduct in washington
and went to his
hometown into a last journey to columbia
for a fundraiser there his medical bills
were considerable
and that showed the
state of affairs as he stared death
in the face for the first time
he never thought that he somehow thought
he was going to beat this demon and even
when the doctors told him he had a year
to live he thought that this new
procedure would extend it to five or
even 10 years
there was some medical optimism there
that was just unrealistic did you ever
meet him never met him why did you get
interested in doing this story
i'm not sure
it is really
it's been a bizarre journey for me
in 1992 i was working on another book a
revised edition of my book the craft of
interviewing
and all the books that i've done have
been for journalists or for writers
i did a craft of interviewing i did
craft of the screenwriter
and during the fall or the during august
of 1992
my daughter lindy a teenage daughter age
14 was visiting me in boston
lindy lives in cincinnati i'm a divorced
dad
and we were
traveling around a little bit doing some
things and she wanted to go to l.l bean
in
freeport maine so we're driving from
boston up to freeport
and of course the
talk shows on
the stations in maine were filled with
discussions of the 92 campaign
and you may remember it was a terrible
campaign for george bush
he was
sputtering he was
off message he was giving interviews
from the backs of golf carts at country
clubs
and bill clinton was looking formidable
ross perot was doing damage in the
republican ranks
and one of the
talk show hosts on this radio show that
we were listening to said
if lee atwater were alive today george
might have a chance
and my daughter looked at me she said
who was lee atwater
and i told her what i could remember
which wasn't much just that he had been
this hard charging campaign manager and
that in 1988 he had taken george bush's
campaign from a 17 point deficit
after the conventions that summer to an
eight-point victory
it was a 25-point swing i said along the
way atwater
disemboweled
michael dukakis who was governor of
massachusetts and it was a campaign that
i had watched slightly i'm not a very
political person i'm a registered
independent i'm from massachusetts which
doesn't have
very warm feelings toward republicans or
toward
george bush in light of that campaign
but i'm also uh i guess
a curious journalistic type
and so
i said to lindy when we get back from
this trip why don't we go to the library
and get a book about atwater we always
read something
as a summer project
we went to the library
and there was no book about lee atwater
and the librarian in this little town
where i live
just north of boston
said that it's very unusual
because there are over 3000 references
to lee atwater in either other books or
in major magazine and newspaper articles
but there is no book about atwater and
then she looked at me and she said there
probably should be a book about atwater
so i asked for a couple of those
articles about atwater began reading
them and i answered my daughter's
question
that week
but i it became um
an interest in uh
in
the details of a man's career and his
life
that
were almost obsessive
i uh
i called columbus i called columbia
south carolina to see if harvey atwater
was in the phone book and i ended up
talking with toddy
she said that her husband had died and
she filled me in a few of the
particulars
and we began a series of conversations
each morning for about 10 days
i told her i'd like to do a book about
you son she said several have tried and
they've all ended up nowhere so i sent
her my credentials a copy of one of my
books
and i began to interview her each
morning for about an hour 45 minutes to
an hour
i would talk until she started to cry
because it was very painful for her to
go through some of these details
i
recorded the conversation use
conversations use them as the beginning
of a book proposal that i pulled
together i called mary matalin in
washington she was in the phone book at
the time not quite as
as famous then as she is these days
and i
asked her if i could talk about lee she
said she hadn't been able to talk about
and that
she was reluctant to do so but she might
give me 10 or 15 minutes about an hour
and a half later we were still talking
and it became apparent that people have
been around at water
over the years
and who had watched him rise and then
be struck down by this tumor
were still not quite over the shock of
his death and what it had done to them
and certainly to the republican party
and to
campaign subsequent
to the 88 campaign
and it just it was a fascinating story
it had almost elements almost a
shakespearean tragedy
a guy who came out of nowhere who had no
no particular political calling except
for what he made
what he made on his own
and who at the age of 29 was in the
reagan white house at the age of 38 was
chairman of the republican national
committee
i probably if i were to meet lee atwater
in person probably would not be his
friend
i don't think that he was particularly
likable
that is for journalists
i think if i worked for him i would find
him fascinating and maybe hate him and
love him at the same time
but as a subject for a biography he was
fascinating i ended up talking with over
almost 400 people
but 150 are mentioned in the book many
would only talk to me on the basis of
confidentiality or for off the record
many of them are in politics or who are
still doing business today
and
i will only say that it took about four
years to do this book i started in 1992
as that campaign wound down
it's now in print after the 96 campaign
along the way i went through a divorce
and my ex-wife who's a good sport and
she and i are on very good terms but at
one point she said to me as we were
heading for the mediator you know if i
were to name a
[Music]
source of uh
difficulty for this this whole thing it
would be lee atwater
as though i invited him into my life and
into the house and he just consumed
four years of
my riding life certainly
where is home right now home is boston
north of boston and what do you do for a
living
well i'm a magazine consultant i work
with magazines that are having some
difficulty i'm a former magazine editor
i've edited boston magazine writer's
digest i'm a founding editor of the
artists magazine and so i have a
consulting firm that
works along those lines i also teach
i recently
spent a semester at the university of
missouri as the hearst visiting
professor
in the journalism department
and i write books
the
mention of mary madeline brings to mind
this uh picture right down here what was
their relationship
well it started out
as a um
that's the two of them they're aware
right now where that is at the
the um
one of the in the the one of the
inaugural balls that lee put together
and it was called the
uh festival for young americans
and it was a for the most part a
blues celebration and they are dancing
in the aisles while the party went on it
was a
their relationship began actually during
the 88 campaign and lee knew mary but he
knew her mostly through rich bond and
rich bond was not his friend they were
in fact political enemies rich bond
would not be republican national
committee chairman right after
afterwards i want to have water's death
actually
um mary came up and it was therefore
sort of a bond person or a bondite and
lee hired her
begrudgingly to assist with the
iowa campaign
in the primaries of the 88
campaign for george bush
things were not going well in iowa and
george bush ended up coming in third
in iowa behind uh
uh
dole and
i'm throwing a blank on the pat roberts
pat robertson i came out of nowhere and
somehow won that that primary
and in a moment of uh of anger lee went
out to iowa on air force two and
ceremoniously fired mary matlin from her
duties as a field director
she sort of hit out and ended up in
michigan
running another campaign for the
republican cause she worked her way back
into his favor
but they started out as i would say
enemies but
he did not think much of her she worked
her way up
the republican
structure and by the time
the after the 88 campaign
when he was putting his staff together
he hired her as his chief of staff
and they were very close
they were
she in effect ran the office while lee
was on the road as you probably know the
role of republican national committee
chairman
requires a lot of road work a lot of
fundraising and someone has to run the
office and that was mary's job
they were
they were
a good team in that after a while mary
was really on his wavelength she could
anticipate things she knew what he was
thinking
and they worked well together i want to
play for you just a minute of a clip she
appeared on a program here and was asked
about this book and here's what she said
about it
i loathed the expert in the excerpt in
the washington post which not surprising
to me because it was the washington post
pulled out the most heinous
of the chapters it's not otherwise it's
not very well done
a biography of an of an incredible man
the washington post ran uh the uh the
last weeks of his life when he was and
did not and
this is why the book is not that well
done it this author did not make it
clear and there are some really tragic
and horrible
and psychotic events taking place at the
end of lee atwater's life when he was
dying from a brain tumor and this author
did not make it clear that the
biological organic effects of a brain
tumor
were there which were
was what was causing this irrational
behavior not that lee was a rational or
those caretakers around him were
irrational but he literally his brain
was literally being disintegrated and i
thought it was ugly for the washington
post to put only that part in their
excerpts and i think the book is
otherwise not a very well chronicled
biography of an extraordinary man
well i beg to disagree uh i think that
there are two
parts to mary's answer uh one the
washington post expert excerpt is a
condensation of last chapter and because
the post did
take some rather
lurid events and
crunch them together
using a little bit of seam work between
them
there there is a quality almost a
a sensational quality to the washington
post extra
and it also
had a in your face style of uh design
that is the pictures and photos that
were used by the washington post were a
little more tabloid like and they
weren't the ones in the book
they were no they were they were
they took one photo from the book or
from the photographer who provided a
photo and they just used like a tight
cropping of
the face of
of uh
brook vosberg and
there was just a more of a tabloid style
to the washington post because that's a
weekly magazine
i think the the book itself the
biography shows
clearly the effects of medi medication
and of the and the gradual decline in
the physical debilitation of this man
uh the
the book i i think
i'll i'll stand on it on its own merits
i don't think that mary uh made that
that point clear that the book does
point out for example that lee had spent
by the end of his first year
160 days in the hospital and i chronicle
all of the uh side effects that that the
medic medication clearly had do you have
any sense of why she feels so strongly
about the book though i mean did you
know this
no i don't
no
i i can't imagine she was a source for
for some information in the book but of
course
i spoke as i said with hundreds of
people and
i
i'll stand by the book so far i've i've
not had
anyone tell me i got anything wrong in
it let me give you a reaction of people
that live in this town because i want to
get to this part of the book when they
opened up their washington post on that
sunday morning a couple of weeks ago
and i've heard this from more than one
person they looked at and they said i
don't want to read any more about lee
atwater
because his story been told and they
began to read it
and then they began to say could you
believe that and how painful it was
and uh then we've i found a lot more
people you know had read it than you
would expect to because
death was a number of years ago yeah are
you surprised at that if somebody would
have that reaction to that washington
post excerpt
the reaction being being a strong
reaction they couldn't believe what they
were reading they couldn't believe what
they were not they couldn't believe that
you were right they just couldn't
believe how painful it was
well it's um i mean i guess i'm asking
for you to characterize
that last 50 pages i mean was it hard to
write
i will tell you this the first draft of
this book was sixteen hundred pages long
that's half a million words
when the publisher saw that he said
there's no way we can do this this book
i said how about two or three volumes on
leah water
uh i was joking of course
he said well my edit editor said if we
can get this down to 400 or 500 pages
we'll have a book so i crunched half a
million words down to about 140 150 000
words
everything that is in the book is as
hemingway says like the tip of the
iceberg
there's a lot more that isn't in the
book so that everything in the book is i
think accurate and and
carefully documented and
it is a uh
[Music]
i think a pretty sound piece of
journalism
the events are often shocking
what lee did how he did things the
backstage story these are things that
have never been told because lee
controlled the message mary was part of
the
business of controlling the message
and i will say i spoke with a lot of
sources that were still spinning the
same old lee atwater tales oh lee lee
read two books a week oh leave this only
that and i would listen politely
almost naively which is
interviewer's technique and you get more
information that way and then you go
back and you
you check for the accuracy of this
source as opposed to other people who
were in the room and who really who knew
what was really going on that is lee
wasn't reading books lee was getting a
summary of books
fed to him by his research staff
and he would get an index card
summarizing exactly what the book was
about and he could memorize
what the
just of the story was could go into a
conversation and he had tremendous
conversational skills tremendous
uh inter-personal skills and you would
swear that he had read the book he
hadn't didn't have to didn't have time
to do it and as he got bigger and bigger
it became more apparent that lee was
dependent upon others to do things in
his spirit in his manner that created
some problems too
let me show
you three pictures you've seen the
audience probably hasn't
of
it looks like the same scene let's look
at the first one and tell us who these
people are okay
this is lee atwater with brooke vosberg
and
it's
part of the series of photographs taken
by
lynn johnson for the life magazine piece
and this was not a published photograph
i saw the entire file at life magazine
nearly 2 000 photographs and
this is a picture of
lee with sally his wife in the back of
the limousine the first one was
limousine too wasn't it yeah these are
all taken in the same
limo i believe this is his wife that's
sally right and then who's this
and uh this is linda reed o'meara
and lee and this is in front of the
white house which you can see in the
background there
same limo
a day of driving around washington
uh linda reid o'meara was an old
friend of lees who would we knew from
south carolina who had helped him on and
off over the years in various political
functions and who spent the last six
months of her life
in the at water home
cooking
helpingly out reading the bible to him
being a personal assistant
and
helping
ease the pain as he
as he
dwindled and died let's go back to the
picture of rick vosberg because she
plays a role in the last 50 pages that i
think that's what everybody's talking
about around after this was published
who is she
and
what was her role in the last year of
his life brook vosberg
is a um is was lee's personal assistant
she came to that job
uh just before
or at the beginning of his his term as
chairman of the republican national
committee
uh previous to that she'd been in the
white house she had been donald regan's
personal assistant she assisted regan in
his year of writing his book
and she'd worked for various other
politicians in the
on the washington scene
and
she
became a an intimate of of lee's
uh so much so that he pretty much turned
a lot of his personal life over to her
in the last year of his life
and
there
was a certain amount of confusion in the
household as a result of that
and it's uh
it's something i like chronicle in uh in
the context of that last year but what
kind of i mean explain what you're
talking about confusion in the household
well lee
had a of course a long-standing marriage
with sally and they had three children
three little girls in fact sally was
pregnant with their third child when lee
was struck with a brain seizure in march
of 1990
and
the
the marriage while
it was long-standing was not
not without some difficulties along the
way
uh
the
the marriage was
a difficult one in that lee was married
i'd say to his job more than to his his
wife and to his family
he was not around for a lot of things
that dads are usually around for
sally was very tolerant i think that
she at one point
acknowledged a friend that she perhaps
was was not strong enough was not strong
enough
with lee
and that
he he got away with with a lot of
misbehavior
the
the what i i'm talking about in the last
year
has to do with the fact that
lee
took his office and
after the seizure he had to move it into
his home
his home became not only a home but a
base of operations for everything that
he was doing therefore his staff his
personal staff
took some precedence over his family in
his home
and you have this upstairs downstairs
kind of arrangement
and he told sally that
that brook was going to be central to
this he also told his
his mother and his father
that brook was
very important to him and that that was
the way things were to be
and by and large they went along with
that arrangement
then you in your book you talk about
vosberg who where is she now by the way
i'm
i'm not able to talk about my sources or
whereabouts
uh she's still in washington no
she's not and did you talk to her i mean
you quote her in the book at all brooke
is the source for the book yes she's
doing very well
elsewhere
but it was the first time it was ever
published that she was very much in that
house every day and
she would be upstairs with lee and her
wife would be downstairs i mean that's
what i guess what mary madeline's
talking about is that this was the first
time that was ever published
i i think that there are a lot of
details that are
that are part of the true story of lee's
life as opposed to the spun version
uh which was manufactured by mary among
others
and sally lee's wife was pregnant at the
time during this his last year of his
life right and that i i think i wrote
the date down had a child on april the
16th middle of april 1990
91 he died in 91 excuse me 1990 90. um
why did you feel it necessary to tell
the whole personal side of this
it's actually the personal side of lee's
life that interests me
that is that's the human drama i think
that
the
political story
which is told as well
is impossible to separate from the
personal story because his personality
was such a part of his career
what he was is a large in large measure
reflection of who he was
and
it seemed that
the way that he conducted his life the
way that he used people is very
very much
a part of who lee atwater ultimately is
i felt that that was my responsibility
to stay with the story
for better and for worse
you write on page 282 there was great
tenderness and intimacy in their
relationship talking about brooke brooke
bathedly care for him like a loving
spouse but no one could determine
whether they were in fact lovers an aide
came into the bedroom one night and
found lee and brooke fast asleep but saw
an innocence to the scene he tiptoed out
and got the third degree from toddy the
next day toddy was in the house yes
where was she
that varied um
people were sleeping
often
you know where wherever they they might
be able to to find a spot i'm not sure
that toddy was in the house that
specific night she may have come over in
the morning but she was in the house
during this whole situation
toddy was in and out of the house on a
regular basis yes
would you say during this period that he
found god
yes in what way and how did you find
that out and how i mean that was part of
the life magazine story too i guess
lee found god but here again
there is a
certain quality
to this religious conversion that i
would say is
subject to
a different kind of evaluation i don't
think that he was
a born-again christian
i think that
he arrived
at a point where he was physically
struck down
and he was looking for
various
things that he could use in his battle
against this enemy against this cancer
he saw religion
as a possibility
and he
traveled that road
he spoke with billy graham he spoke with
a catholic priest he was baptized by a
catholic priest
and
he spoke with a lot of
non-denominational
religious leaders
he
had buddhist monks visit
there is a quality of desperation in
this religious search it has
to me
the more the aura of someone who is
looking for religion
not out of fervor but out of fear
i also
came across some tape recordings that he
made on his deathbed of his prayers
where'd you find those by the way i
cannot tell you
i've i have a lot of things that were
given to me by individuals and
and they're
they're they're from my use but uh not
for attraction but you tell us in the
book that he recorded them by himself in
his on his deathbed he had a little
micro cassette recorder and lee had
another habit during his life he would
often record people who were unaware of
the fact that they were being recorded
he would conduct or give interviews to
journalists and
they would have their recorders but he
would have a recorder somewhere else to
make a copy of it so he could check
their quotes get back to them later if
they had misquoted him and he would have
evidence
i found some long interviews that he did
he
recorded a lot of the conversations he
had with the writer
who did the life magazine piece toward
the end of lee's life
a lot of these things came my way in the
process of making my rounds with various
sources
and i felt that i got as close to leat
waters psyche as you can get
in listening to these these private
recordings where there's no one but lee
talking to himself
and these were recordings that often had
other things on them as well some
household business and things that you
might
put on a tape recorder if you use it as
a little bit of a memory device because
he couldn't write
he was somewhat incapacitated he
couldn't even take notes
these prayers are all
pretty much of the quality that
dear god
if you will
help me through this if you will
make me better you will give me a
victory in this i will be you the best
foot soldier you could ever want in your
army there's usually a quid pro quo in
lee's prayers
and
i think that he was trying to make a
deal with god much as you'd make a deal
with someone in order to get a political
victory i think that was lee's nature i
think that was the essence of lee
to the end trying to manipulate trying
to manage people trying to have his way
with them
trying to
serve some inner need something that was
within himself
that was almost insatiable
so
i found myself
uh
dealing with someone who was
in some ways not particularly admirable
but
there was a price that he paid for it as
well
in the public arena
he became someone who was known as a
trigger man someone who could pull the
trigger a cold-blooded political killer
therefore and he often encouraged this
he'd like to to take
credit for things
that were bad campaigns that were nasty
mean had some elements of dirty tricks
in them he'd like to take credit for
that because it was good for business
being a bad boy in politics well there's
a market for that a lot of politicians
like that in their managers
the downside of it was that lee was
easy to accuse of things
and
he would often
he couldn't deny things even though he
perhaps had nothing to do with them
because he lacked a certain amount of
credibility
this occurred
most
tellingly after the 88 election
during the 1988 election perhaps the
most famous ad was the so-called willie
horton head
well there are two willy horton ads
there is an ad that was done by the
republican national committee excuse me
by the by the
bush quail campaign
it's an ad
that does not mention willie horton's
name it's an ad that does not use willie
horton's image
it's called the revolving door
and in the ad
there are
prisoners going through this revolving
door out in a desert-like setting
and there's commentary on the
furlough
the prison furlough system in
massachusetts and how
governor michael dukakis
was allowing
convicted murderers who
were
not eligible for parole
these murders were allowed out on the
street
on weekend furloughs unsupervised
and as a result of that willie horton
a murderer who was in massachusetts
prisons in concord
escaped
to maryland
where he terrorized a couple he tied
them up he raped the woman twice
he slashed the stomach of the guy 22
times threatening to kill him at any
moment
and eventually he was captured
by the maryland police
but
what the what this case did was it
showed
how
questionable the crimes the the uh
the caucus style of
crime control in massachusetts was
and
atwater decided to use this case and to
help create this ad but the ad did not
mention willie horton by name and did
not use his image it showed prisoners
going through this revolving door i've
read articles even by pretty well-known
journalists in which they say most of
the prisoners going through the store
are black and it's a racist ad
well it's not
of the 19 prisoners who go through the
revolving door 16 are white
two are black one is what might be
called mexican or mexican-american
the problem is that there was another ad
which was done by an independent group
the national security political action
committee floyd brown floyd brown and
larry mccarthy was the guy who did the
actual ad
this group came out with an ad at about
the same time we're talking about late
september and early october of 1988
and this featured an image of michael
dukakis and an image of willie horton
and mentioned this
this case that i've just outlined
and this was for a group called
americans for bush very ambiguous effort
to raise money for the
independent expenditure group
and it created a lot of confusion
the confusion was so complete
that people to this day blame lee
atwater for the so-called willie horton
ad
uh it was mentioned in in a
i've seen it in a review of my book that
misunderstood completely
who did what
and when atwater died in
1991
when his obituary was the lead item on
the three network shows two of the three
cbs and abc
got it wrong as an image
on screen while they were talking about
lee atwater they ran excerpts from the
willy horton ad that lee had nothing to
do with
i've gone through all the files all of
the correspondence between
this
ms pac group and the bush quail campaign
there's no evidence to indicate any
connection between the two
there's only suspicion
and there's and because you have lee
atwater there there's a tendency to
think the worst susan estrich took
advantage of this
in
december of 88 after the campaign was
over at harvard
she ran the dukakis campaign two susan
dukakis ran the dukakis campaign some
would say that she probably did a very
poor job of running that campaign could
not keep the the candidate on message
and actually the democrats ran a racist
ad in california
it's an ad that features a
mexican
american
[Music]
murderer a man who killed his wife in
front of their two children this image
the image of this murderer and
george bush
are brought together in an ad that ran
in california
and
if there ever was a racist ad it is that
in a state that is often defined by its
racial content
but
in the aftermath of the 88 campaign
during which racism was not a charge
susan estrich began to suggest that in
using willie horton as an example of the
dukakis
ineptitude
lee atwater had created a racist
campaign and she qualified it to some
degree in discussions but later in march
or rather in may of
of
1989 the washington post magazine ran a
cover story called willie horton and me
by susan estridge in which she laid out
an even stronger case for it being a
racist campaign
equating
the
crime issue
with uh
with uh
saying that it was a racist issue people
equate crime with blacks that was her
logic
i'm not sure that that would play
i i don't think that that's that's a
fair statement to say that when people
think of crime they think of blacks i
don't i don't think that that's an
accurate assessment of the american
intelligence
and yet
it reinforced this idea that atwater and
willie horton and racism had a lot to do
with that campaign
that campaign was a lot of things but
the willy horton issue
was distorted that was in 88 and
he ran that campaign yes
and they won
and george bush became president 89 yes
when was he struck first day when did he
know
the first time that he had a brain tumor
on march 6 of 1990 he had a seizure what
during a fundraiser
for phil graham in washington and it
occurred in the morning he'd been
feeling ill for several days
but
it came out of nowhere
and he had a limp for about six months
in his left leg but they attributed to
his uh
his heavy schedule of uh travel and
normal fatigue plus the fact that he ran
six miles a day
and he was
he was struck with a seizure in march of
uh 1990.
he knew at the end of the next day
that it was a
a
high-grade tumor and by the end of that
month he was talking with medical
specialists who were estimating that he
had a year or two to live
then he decided to go for this
interstitial procedure that i mentioned
earlier they you actually somewhere you
say that you got some record all the
records at george washington hospital
yes did they just give them
over to you no no i had to get
permission from sally and of course from
all the
uh
from sally basically to to look at all
the the medical records how cooperative
was sally with this book and what's she
think of it you know sally was very
cooperative and uh i admire quite a bit
for her openness and candor um i think
this is probably a painful read for
sally in part
there are things here that obviously a
biographer learns that
that people in the story do not know
and that's probably true for
many people who knew lee atwater
he was a a very complex man who kept
everybody in a little box and they only
knew so much about him
enough to be
useful for him enough to be
to serve a purpose
but
they did not get to know the the whole
man and
i think that uh
it was john singer's sergeant
the
painter who said that every time i
complete a portrait i make an enemy
where's sally today
sally's in washington
raising three children and uh is
somewhat active in
republican political circles
and at the very end of their life
together when he died by the way where
was he when he died he died here at
george washington hospital
and you say that george
uh at least ron reagan and his wife
visited the hospital right yeah ronald
reagan and nancy reagan were the last
visitors actually
james baker came in that same night
maybe i think he came in after the
reagan's what was sally and lee's
relationship at the end
at the end they were together at the
finish line they had resolved a lot of
their
their
problem areas and uh you say there was a
time at that uh
leatwater wanted to go through a
marriage ceremony with brooke vosberg
there at the hospital they had a little
wedding a little marriage ceremony in
the chapel at the hospital
somewhat symbolic
and but eventually lee
separated himself from brook
and
she was not at the funeral
in the back you have this picture of the
gravesite where is this by the way
that's in columbia south carolina
and you can't see it here in the
photograph we've transferred it to a
picture so that people on the screen can
see it that's what it looks like there
in
1951 to 91 you say he was just a little
bit over 40 and you say teacher leader
husband father
son
uh and then
it goes into the republican creed and we
can put that on the screen so people can
read exactly what it says where'd you
find the republican creed is this his
the republican creed is a statement of
purpose that is uh used at certain
republican functions and the decision to
put it on his gravestone was sally's let
me read it so folks who trying to read
and listen to you can do one thing at a
time i do not choose to be a common man
is my right to be uncommon i prefer the
challenges of life to guaranteed
security the thrill of fulfillment to
the state calm of utopia i will never
cower before any master save my god
and who who wrote that you know i do not
know the the author but the first two
lines i do not choose to be a common man
i choose to be an uncommon man are
certainly
very characteristic of
lee atwater's credo
uh it was something he learned
in this first summer of politics in
august of 1971 as a college student
he was in the office
of strom thurmond as an intern and he
did mostly
oh clerical work drove the center around
a little bit and lee was a terrible
driver so i can imagine what those trips
must have been
uh he did not have good
coordination skills lee was somewhat
klutzy
and
for most of their married life sally did
the driving he said he needed the time
to focus on
politics
but he had a conversation with strom
thurmond toward the end of that summer
and he came back for another internship
the following year
trump thurmond was actually a runner uh
during these early years and lee picked
up that habit from him
he
uh strong thurman told lee that you have
a choice in this world you can be a
common man or you can be an uncommon man
and lee
took that to heart at one point
lee had been
just a hard drinking college
guy his weight went up to 200 pounds one
summer
he started running six miles a day he
lost weight he
was always 155 pounds
he was very disciplined very orderly and
he could
resist many many things he stopped
drinking he was once a pretty heavy
drinker he stopped smoking except one
day a week and that was friday he smoked
a pack of cigarettes each friday
and he used that as an example of
self-control people who smoke
cigarettes know how difficult it is to
stop smoking cigarettes did he really
read the prince by machiavelli 21 times
no
did he tell people he did well the
number changed it was a little bit like
joseph mccarthy's communists in the
government uh the number was 10 it was
11 it was 20 21 and i've heard 23.
what's this and this is uh the dots
without the lines drawn are are
available earlier in the book and what's
this about yeah this is that little
challenge i think we all have seen
connecting nine dots with four lines
without lifting your hand from the paper
uh this has
this is the solution and in order to
connect the nine dots with four lines
and not remove your hand from the pen
from the paper you have to go outside
the dots
and that was another metaphor that
patwater used thinking he said when you
think of a solution you have to go
outside the dots you can't stay within
the dots
to sometimes solve a problem or a puzzle
and that's how he approached any
political puzzle you could throw at him
you said earlier you wrote 500 000 words
yes sir what are you going to do with uh
the 140 000 uh or no i guess it'd be 260
000 it didn't make it in there or is it
more than that
uh
all those that or how many did you end
up in the book it's about 150 000. so
what are you gonna do with the other 350
they're in the uh the atwater archives
right now at my at my residence i
i'm not sure
is there something to do
i
i don't know there might be a longer
treatise someday
it's also filled with the tapes i
listened to 18 hours of his recording
sessions with b.b king
chuck jackson
billy preston and all these great blues
artists
it's an interesting thing to listen to
the that is the the tape recording of
lee and these uh these blues artists
because he begins as someone just
strumming along with bb king trying to
learn the tunes
and there's this engaging quality
between the two of them but after a
couple of hours you hear lee
telling the engineer how to handle
things and then by the second session
lee is pretty much telling
everybody how to perform their music
uh he did not he did not like to be
anything less than a leader
and he was a quick learner
and uh
could be quite formidable
before we run out of time i i want to
ask you this and i'll get back to some
more of the substances but on the back i
don't know that i've ever seen this
before you say in order to get the index
you got to go to the world wide web and
we actually plugged in the worldwide web
show what it looks like and there it is
on the screen right there and i've got a
hard copy here why didn't the publisher
want to put your index in well the index
uh
while it's it gives you ease of access
to the to the book uh is a little bit at
odds with what i was trying to do with
this story
i wanted this story to be told as a
whole i wanted
i i tried to
create a certain narrative flow to it
that
made it move from page one to the end
uh the books i studied
in order to put this together included a
biography of elvis presley last train to
memphis by peter garalnick or
the book by connie brook on steve ross
master of the game
and also indecent exposure that
wonderful biography of david biegelman
the study of david biegerman by david
mcclintock
these are great biographies i think of
contemporary figures that are told with
in a narrative way so that there's
there's a story
and a lot of the books of washington
figures have indexes that make them seem
more scholarly and more pedantic than i
think that this book is so there's that
secondly the publisher decided after
studying other books that a lot of
people in washington buy a book by
reading it backwards they look at the
index see if their they are in the book
or someone they know is in the book and
then make a purchasing decision richard
ben cramer's book
what it takes has no index
and it was it was packaged for the same
purpose why should there be an index
when you should buy the whole thing
without wondering who's in it
the paperback version will have an index
i'm told
but the goal here is to
get someone interested in the book and
the index is there if you want to follow
through on the instructions at the back
end there are a couple restaurants in
this town called red hot and blue
uh and then in the back and we we played
some of the music going in we'll play
some of it going out but here's a
is that the is that the cd cover that's
the album cover
and the album of course has been uh
replaced by a cd that is now sold
uh it the album is rather hard to find
it's a collector's item actually because
it has uh bb king and uh
chuck thomas and chuck jackson chuck
jackson and uh
and sam moore of sam and dave and
lots of other folks yeah
and lee atwater singing bad boy among
other things
he was
as i said earlier
unique
in so many ways
one thing he brought to the
the job of the chair of the republican
national committee was a sense of
showmanship that i don't think will ever
be seen again
he put together
blues festivals fundraisers he carried a
guitar that ron wood of the rolling
stones gave him
on uh
on this occasion this is the inaugural
gala that he put together
he was on stage with george bush kind of
mugging along uh pretending to be a
bluesman
and that stratocaster that
that ron wood gave atwater was
like a traveling companion for the next
year that he was in office
he carried it everywhere
sad to say
that stratocaster has disappeared it's
one of the things that was
lost in the confusion
of his final year
and
all the traffic that came and went in
his home which had been turned into an
office and then finally into a
hospital room we're going to close this
again we don't normally do this um but
we're gonna close it with some more from
this album bad boy is a song did he
write it no he didn't but he uh he
customized the lyrics that he used to
fit his unique uh
political career
he added his own touch to it he was a
bad boy from washington dc
well here's the as we listen to the
music here's the cover of the book and
our guest has been john brady and the
name of the book is bad boy the life and
politics of lee atwater
[Music]
john brady is a former editor of boston
magazine and writer's digest he's
currently teaching magazine editing and
writing at the scripps school of
journalism at ohio university in athens
for more information visit
johnbrady.info
this weekend on c-span 2's book tv on
afterwards former educations